sheriff's deputies were forced to
intervene at Fort Lauderdale
International Airport overnight when
passengers erupted in anger after Spirit
Airlines canceled nine flights look at
this video it appears that thousands of
the airlines customers are being
impacted by a dispute between spirit and
its pilots now the pilots say they're
working without a contract spirit
airline says its pilots are engaged in
illegal slowdown the carrier alleges
some are quote engaged in a campaign to
threaten and intimidate other pilots
over flying assignments Manuel Bojorquez
is at Fort Lauderdale Hollywood
International Airport and well good
morning good morning Spirit Airlines
said it is shocked and saddened to see
the video from inside this Airport
overnight the carrier which says it has
canceled more than 150 flights in the
last two days is now asking a court to
intervene with the pilots union and its
passengers appear to be caught in the
middle Broward County sheriff's deputies
intervened at Fort Lauderdale Hollywood
International Airport overnight when
passengers according to police were so
upset they began to fight each other
near the crowded Spirit Airlines
check-in counter very angry angry angry
people
everybody had places to be and couldn't
be there fresh off a cruise debbie
mcgrann d is struggling to get back home
to Detroit this is actually our third
spirit flight that has been canceled
I slept in the airport in Philly already
on Thursday night and I don't want to
sleep in the airport again tonight
spirit says it's service in at least
four major airports including Fort
Lauderdale has taken a hit due to a
contract dispute with its pilots Spirit
filed a lawsuit Monday night alleging in
the last week its pilots have been
engaged in a pervasive illegal work slow
down causing approximately 300 flight
cancellations which is disrupting the
travel of over 20,000 customers spirit
alleges some pilots are refusing to take
certain assignments and are posting in
online forums and websites in a campaign
to threaten and intimidate other pilots
we would not settle for a contract that
defines us as low tier the pilots union
is pushing back against a company making
record profits and insists they are not
engaged in a work slowdown in a
statement of CBS News the airline pilots
association referred to spirit's request
for an injunction as unwarranted and
counterproductive legal action over
night spirit passengers who remain stuck
at Fort Lauderdale said they were
offered vouchers I think that it's all
about money and I think that they're
they shouldn't have been booking flights
they should have told us from the
beginning that this was going on
Spirit Airlines said in a legal document
that it relies on the status quo when it
comes to asking its pilots to work
overtime and the carrier says its
reputation will continue to suffer as
long as the pilot dispute continues but
the self-proclaimed low-cost carrier
also acknowledged that both parties are
quote far apart on pay rates gale yeah
but you wouldn't say to the adults the
children are watching thank you very
much thank you very much Manuel